ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show live from Los Angeles
California hey guys it's been a 'very
the producer we have a special treat for
you tonight it's the best of patreon vol
1 so I went through 6 of my favorite
episodes and found excerpts from them
and what we're gonna play for you is
just sort of the tip of the iceberg when
it comes to everything we have behind
that pay wall on the patreon if you want
to go find those episodes that I pulled
stuff from I will have links in the
description it's only $5 a month
patreon.com slash the Tim Dylan show
it's a way to get a bonus RSS feed that
me and Tim put stuff out on we have a
lot of great great great episodes on
there not even to mention we have a
hundred forty-five archives of old
episodes of the show with interviews
with CIA agents russ Baker Nick Bryant
there's tons of stuff with Tim and Ray
that's absolutely hysterical along with
a lot of other comedians on the patreon
bonus episodes now we're around 29 bonus
episodes so far that feature gown is
Papa's crista Stefano Jessa read and a
lot of other comedians mostly it's just
Tim doing solo or Tim and Ray so go
check out the patreon patreon comm slash
the Tim Dillon show so I'm now going to
play you six things I pulled from random
patreon episodes that I really liked
this first one is from the first bonus
episode titled bill and Hills last kill
this episode was recorded on August 17th
2019 this is one of my favorite episodes
Tim also has a great uber story at the
beginning of this but I'm just going to
play the part where he imagines Bill and
Hillary's celebrating the last kill they
ever had best case these people know
what's going on let's say let's say
Clint never [__] any of the epstein
girls let's save
I don't believe it but let's just say it
let's say it okay let's just ha let's
say he never [__] the abstain girl are
you telling me he didn't know what was
going on he's a Rhodes Scholar he's not
an idiot he's not a [__]
he would say george w bush's a [__] he
wasn't a [__] he wasn't like the type
of intellectual that had you know you
know he wasn't like a brilliant guy but
he wasn't a [__] these people have a
savvy pretty good understanding of the
forces around them it's how they're able
to stay alive it's how they're able to
rise through the ranks they understand
the landscape quite well and if Jeffrey
Epstein is out there with a [__]
island he wasn't really keeping quiet
about it folks he had his own Island you
don't think there was chatter what's
going on on that island what's happening
over there you know the President of the
United States you know the ex-president
now okay they all knew folks they all
know and whether Clanton whether bill
and he'll bill and he'll whether they
like they didn't order ahead that's
probably not the way that it works
Hilary's not you know texting somebody
you know go and whack this guy but I'll
tell you this the people that they work
for the people that the bushes work for
that the crime families that really run
the country why do you call them crime
because they commit crimes and then they
cover up those crimes
that's why I call them crime family um
you know other than the good stuff they
do the stuff that we all know about the
corporate fraud and military
militarization of the police force and
locking everybody up that's all the
conventional we know they did that
that's the stuff they're allowed to
write about in the New York Times and
you know cuz that's all that's all stuff
that we don't we don't doubt that the
private prisons and all that we all know
that's real but the stuff that you're
not allowed to talk about kid [__]
Island that type of stuff we always have
some hard time believing that they knew
what was going on or that they were
participating in it we're like well
listen we know that they take donations
from people that lock up in essential we
know that and we know that they bomb
aspirin factories in Sudan and we know
that and we know that they intimidate
and threaten women that they've tried to
rape who come forward we know that we
know that and we know that a lot of the
people that they do shady business deals
with end up killing themselves by
shooting themselves twice in the head we
know that but there's no way that they
would ever ever participate in something
as gruesome as [__] underage kids we
draw the line there that doubt they
wouldn't do they wouldn't be involved in
that um yeah they would yeah they would
because it's a great way it's a great
way to control people
that is why intelligence agencies have
used that method of sexual blackmail
forever that is why the Mafia is used it
that is why people these operations have
gone on throughout history they're still
going on there's a new Jeffrey Epstein
there's a new Island folks there's a new
island and it's bigger and better than I
bet yeah and this is a great rare
concept this the Catholic Church and
probably like why don't you let us go
back to running this dude [__] please
let's just get back to it there's a new
island now with
in waterslides where after you're done
with the kids they go right down the
waterslide into a furnace trust me
the new islands gonna be bigger and
better it's gonna they're gonna
advertise it they're gonna be like if
you like little st. James you got to
come to Little Bo Peep Little Bo Peep is
the new Island not Jeffrey Epstein from
by another guy Josh Goldberg Josh
Goldberg runs a new Island Little Bo
Peep it's not going away it's not going
away unless there's a massive shift in
consciousness which is probably not
gonna happen because everybody's at
Carl's jr. you know is what it is I'm
not saying that you know you know I
don't want to sound like I'm like Steve
you know I'm uh yeah you know I'm not is
not like I'm like a perfect human being
I'm not calling a little Saint James or
whatever it's called it was called
little st. James but like you know when
I [__] on the people who calls Yunior
I'm we call juniors and all of us the
idea that you just want to go through a
drive-thru and get a you know I get it
it's is there none of us are immune to
that but that is what it you know that
is the choice essentially stay asleep
stay asleep forever or wake the [__] up
and realize that all of the people or
far too many of the people that you
think you know are sociopaths who've
done things that would keep you awake at
night that's all that's all you should
know these people that sit down at Good
Morning America oh hello how are you oh
it's a little cold today isn't it it's a
little it's a little chilly
ah the fall it's so nice the fall those
people you know have done terrifying
terrifying things and you know a lot of
people don't want to believe the acts
they don't really want to live in that
reality and I don't blame them because
I'm certainly no better off for knowing
what I know or having the conversations
that I've had but when [__] like this
happens man
you gotta [__] you gotta wake up how
dumb do you want to be I mean the people
that whack this guy are going oh wait a
minute they there's people that are
saying it's not even it's they're saying
there's no conspiracy like the people
that design this system or have to be
surprised at how well it works they have
to be like oh my god they're not there's
no riots this is great I mean there
should be riots there should be 10,000
people outside of that pray there should
be and William bar or whatever his name
is things William bar who's the Attorney
General is like a CIA [__]
iran-contra good-old-boy and now they're
bringing in a Baden the puts of forensic
pathologist he's involved with JFK and
OJ I mean who's next Kissinger they're
bringing Henry we're gonna get we're
getting to the truth we're getting to
the bottom of this folks we're bringing
in the FBI and we're gonna put the whole
investigation I in the hands of Henry
Kissinger because we want the truth we
want the truth I mean it's really
laughable it's incredibly laughable the
coroner said he's convinced that the
Epstein it was a suicide
now they're saying there's all these
irregularities with the jail and that
yeah well they moved this they moved the
prisoner out of his room two hours
earlier he was off suicide watch the
cameras don't point in to the cells we
don't know there are some irregularities
in the prison you know we don't know
what guards were on that night
there's something weird with the
scheduling and you know it'll all be out
of the news soon it'll all be out of the
news soon folks you'll be back to your
regularly scheduled programming the air
will crisp up fall will be here football
will be here you know
everybody back to their right and
there'll be a little Saint James
there'll be a new Island bigger and
better than ever before don't worry
about it bigger and better and the kids
today are so [__] up they're probably
trying to get on the island they're
emailing they're trying to get on they
want in you don't even have to kidnap
them and can you know they're
volunteering they're like great watch a
few Miley Cyrus videos and they're like
this is great looking on they'll paddle
to the island let me get a few bucks
I'll put out a dirty witch's scrotum on
my face that guy huh man what was it do
you ever imagine do you ever imagine
what it was like when Bill and Hillary
found out and they're sitting now like
you never imagined that I was tweeting
about it it was really funny but like do
you ever really imagine like what when
they found out let's let's assume they
found out on the news and let's assume
it just assumed they found out on the
news you know I'm not convinced but
let's assume they found out on the news
you know they are plugged in there is a
way they did you get some info but let's
assume they found out other news I mean
what is their reaction like looking at
each other what is their because they're
done here's the thing they're done
politically the Clintons and they know
it they're done politically people make
a lot of them they're not dared
nefarious characters but they're not
running the show people don't realize
that it's fun to pretend they are
they're just not um the system they're
part of will outlive that it'll outlive
the bushes it's you know it's designed
to endure it's gonna be round you know
this [__] still goes on you know but I
just am at
Jen you know Bill and Hillary do you
almost like the more I like the more
that they're murderers is that my
problem I like them more because I could
never picture them [__] but I picture
them murdering and I'm like that's what
their love is based on and that to me is
a stronger and a better love it's almost
more pure the need to dominate power at
all costs covering your tracks now
they're like protecting your legacy
protecting their daughter's ambitions
her political ambition you know we can't
have can't have daddy go down in a human
trafficking scandal Chelsea's gonna run
you know Chelsea's gonna run for some
it's a matter of time we love dynastic
politics in this country so that's what
they're doing now I almost like them a
little bit trying hard not to like them
I thought of them like just cooking
pancakes no Epstein's dad and you know
they're robbing your estate york and
they're just cooking pancakes and you
know they've got some music on maybe
like Aretha Franklin or something and
they're just kind of grooving around
like you know Bill's reading the times
and he's got a cup of coffee and they
just have two stacks of pancakes you
know nothing smells better than fresh
pancakes with some maple syrup and
butter and you know Bill's like you know
we never eat like this we don't do this
enough and I always like we don't you
know and they're just sitting there and
he eatin those pancakes and there's a
faint aftertaste of blood you know never
do that ever cut your mouth on a sharp
food or something and you just feel that
little taste of blood just a little
blood in your mouth I feel like Bill and
Hillary always have a little blood taste
in their mouth they like it you know
they're just heating the pancakes and
you know it's just a date so close but
they just ditch - dodged another [__]
bullet and it's probably the last one
they have to dodge they're getting
[__] old
is probably their last high-five moment
and it's hard to not kind of it's hard
to not respect them a little bit and be
like you did it you made it to the end
you know now of course goes without
saying demons from hell goes without
saying but you know there's something
about that they did it you know get a
Fleetwood Mac don't stop thinking about
tomorrow up this was the song that Bill
and Hillary when they won in 92 or that
the convention like Fleetwood Mac played
it and put this on yeah it's a great I
just feel like you know they're up in
Chappaqua and they're just starting up
the groove and Bill goes you know it's
been a long time since we cut a rug like
this and they just start dancing and in
the background there's the television is
talking about how Epstein hung himself
in the salad and they're just jumping
around and all these dumb [__] on
Twitter with the blue checks already
like god Wayne and these conspiracy
Nazis they're just [__] trying to
connect all these things and Hillary and
Bill it dance and because guess what
they never stop thinking about tomorrow
they never did and it'll be here better
than before because they believe they
believe they believe what that [__]
screenwriter didn't it's the little
[__] things you're gonna do what you
don't want to do you dumb [__] okay
and you end up respecting them yes they
[__] kids and eat them and murder them
and put them in a food processor and
make a meatloaf out of them who gives a
[__] you know what they don't do they
don't drive a [__] over so guess what
I would vote for them over and over
again now because they've proved it they
proved they could make it happen
in the [__] tightest security jail
cell
oh [__] you they did it
Bill and Hillary Clinton they came out
of the swamps those white-trash
ranch dressing eating Arkansas pigs and
they did it the old-fashioned way
rape and murder you know and it brings a
tear to your eye it really does
now I know I know it's their badge I get
it I get it I'm not I'm not an idiot
but when I think about them dancing in
their estate celebrating their latest
kill god I shed a tear because they were
my [__] childhood my boomer parents
loved them my piece of [__] worthless
family loved them they were our future
and there's something about my childhood
that it dies with them and you know what
there's something beautiful about that
there's something truly remarkable about
the way they did it folks
they won and there's something to be
said for winning and Hillary just sips
that blood smoothie pours hot sauce on
an aborted fetus and starts chewing a
foot
and you know what I know that it's not
right get stand by me up and I just
picture after the days you know they've
had a long day they're on the phone with
a lot of people you know and talking to
their friends and everything they're
just they're just they're just looking
at each other and there's a light breeze
there's a light summer breeze and they
realize that they have a sadness peak
it's a bittersweet feeling because this
they look at each other and they don't
vocalize it but they know that there's a
great possibility that this was their
last kill and they realized this was
probably the last time they arranged a
man to have his life ended to protect
bill and god only knows what she's into
and they realize it they realize this is
the last operation we've done we've done
a lot we've done Vince Foster we did a
lot of people there's too many to name I
mean there's so many Pete I mean dogs
have killed themselves that these
[__] have met and there's just
something so nice if I can't I can't not
think there's something beautiful about
a couple that truly truly loves each
other in the real sense not the [__]
sense you go on a cruise together oh you
raise kids to get none of that I mean
you have enemies and you get rid of them
one by one you know
and I just think of them in their
Chappaqua mansion and maybe maybe
they're drinking red wine they loved red
they don't like wide and low red and
they're just kind of swaying swaying
watching the coverage rolling you know
you know maybe george w bush text them a
couple of emojis he knows he knows
prince andrew text them they text prince
andrew back LOL oh they're happy they're
demons but guess what there are demons
and they'll disappear the cleanse will
disappear with the monterey ranch
chicken sandwich of the 1990s one of the
greatest things that's ever been baking
in the ranch dressing oh [__] you
they'll disappear with the great economy
of the 90s the pre 9/11 just a just a
careless carefree boomer attitude he'll
just disappear and they'll fade away but
before they did they had one last kill
this next segment is from bonus episode
6 put it on the ham where Tim tells a
really funny story about growing up and
to lead into that story it's going to
start with Tim talking about the passing
of the late great Karl Ruiz you know we
all have those moments where you look
around and you go I gotta get out of
here whatever here is mm-hmm
you know you might be in a party you
might be in a bar you might be in a
relationship you might be at a job you
just look around you a guy gotta get the
[__] out of here and I gotta try to
figure out how I got here how did they
get here right and where and how do I
get somewhere else and Carl was a [__]
character man he was very funny is funny
the most comedians you know
he was passionate about food loved
wouldwould review like you know the
popeyes chicken sandwich he'd review
like fast food he'd review everything he
loved working-class people genuinely
genuinely he didn't pretend to yeah he
loved the food that they ate he loved
the places they hung out
he loved the bars that they went to he
spent a lot of time in those places he
would go and get you know chip beef
sandwich upstate he'd go [__] all
over the place and he genuinely loved
those types of people there's a lot of
people in my business to pretend to like
those people on the left and the right
yeah whether you're lean to left to lean
to the right and entertainment there's a
lot of people pretend to like
working-class people which I never have
by the way thank you
isn't that nice I've never really
pretended yeah I've claimed to only be
interested in the super-rich and I've
been pretty consistent about that yeah
you know you got integrity I mean I've
been pretty you know it's like you see
me outside of a factory and like don't
close it what no I listen I like working
with a pile of characters and I won't
even have health insurance and stuff
like that but I mean the people that
interest me are rich people I've been
very honest about that because I think
they're doing a lot of [__] up wild
[__] these are those are the people that
I not to say that like you know I'm
working class all my friends are working
class everyone I grew up with and I know
is working-class so it's not like those
are the fun or people those that people
want to perform comedy for you know what
Karl literally loved those people met
Karl really cared about people he cared
about the guys that were line cooks he
cared about the guys that he stood next
to in the kitchen he gave a [__] about
all of those people and it's just so
funny because he didn't advertise it in
the way that people do in this business
mmm when they're like I love the working
class like he never said that he just
loved the working class selfies with
janitors yeah he just cared about people
yeah man he can he care and he went to
the places they hung out and he loved
you know the food and he understood it
and he was like [__] he understood
people's relationship with food and that
some of it was destructive some of it
was you know he got I think to be fully
great I mean I I since I was a kid I've
loved restaurants and food and a whole
culture of it and a lot of it mirrors
the culture of drugs or an access or you
know anything
and there's rituals there's you know all
that stuff involved in eating and in
taking drugs and use drugs and drinking
and sax or whatever it is and Carl kind
of understood maybe better than so many
other people the role that food played
especially in the lives of people who
didn't have a lot and this was a fun
thing for them to do the food and drink
was actually a fun thing to do was kind
of this escape it was a release it was a
place where even if they didn't have a
lot of money that could save some money
to go to a nice restaurant and it's an
indulgence and they enjoyed it they
could afford that they could never
afford a Maserati they could never
afford a house in the hills of LA they
could never afford a mansion you know
wherever and wherever but they were able
to go out and eat something good and I I
was always a guy who the only things I
ever did with money was go out and eat
so Carl got that he I think he
understood that food was important to
people especially working-class people
people that didn't have enough you know
and he you know he had this whole thing
rui-zhi
it was hashtag reason which was rui-zi I
mean I think a few days before he died
or week before he died he was like on
the Long Island Rail Road heading out to
Long Island and he tweeted will somebody
meet me with a pack of cigarettes and
and and some white cloth something at
the train station and immediately it
happened you know like a guy was waiting
for him as soon as he got off the train
but that's what Carl would do there were
no strangers in you know and I'll talk
about this a little bit on the on the
regular episode not not as long but like
that guy didn't they weren't did we do
Frant like it sounds cliche and stupid
like oh there are people that are that
guy there was no strangers there were
just friends he hadn't met yet but that
guy made friends with people you know he
just wanted to hang out he wanted to
drink he wanted to eat he wanted to
laugh that's all he wanted to do he
didn't want to hurt anybody he didn't
want to be powerful you want to he
didn't wanna Bews people he didn't want
to Lord power over everybody he
genuinely was passionate about cooking
about laughing and you know that's a
[__] great example of somebody who
lives who really lives who they are like
you know but it sucks because I would
have rather dim be around for a lot
longer you know which is why I think you
do have to moderate that dude you can't
go as hard all the time as you want to
go there's you know and I'm not you know
he's a very successful guy he's very
talented guy you know and he could up
you know it's very sad that he wasn't
around for as long as he could have been
you know and I don't know the
circumstances of his death but I just do
know that you know he was rui-zi
you know he went out he drank he ate he
laughed he had fun with people you know
yeah and that's a shitty thing you know
but I mean that's all I can do is
basically say to myself like I want to
be around for a while you know and
whatever that means by someone have fun
and I still want to be the type of guy
that he was I think you have to work
harder at being fun like if you if you
say to yourself I'm gonna get rid of the
booze I'm gonna get rid of it I'm not
gonna be the guy that just eats
ridiculous [__] uh but I'm I still want
to be fun like I still want people to
like me as to want to be funny and I
still want to like be the life of the
party to an extent like that might be a
little harder but I think it's you got
to do it like I still won't have a
personality you know but I don't want it
to kill me and so many dudes out there
just kills them we know guys not
mentioning their names we know guys you
look at them you go you're being killed
yeah you know like who you are is
killing it
you know and and I just fall into that
trap dude of like not seeing a way out
and not God well I've only been this how
am I gonna be something else you know
you know I mean it's like it's tricky
you know I mean that being said put
Greta Thun Berg in jail put her in jail
throw away the key what a chump say
about her because happy girl happy girl
excited for a bright future yeah I mean
this is who you're putting in a que like
this is he putting in the Roman
Colosseum but Trump the 16 year old
Swedish girl this is how deeply immoral
our society is the master troll
psychopath Donald Trump who has
absolutely no feelings would feed his
own kids to a [__] tiger if you
needed to yeah and we're putting in the
Roman Colosseum with him we're putting a
16 year old Swedish girl autistic
Swedish girl and that's that's what
we're gonna do
seems like not the move you know seems a
little ridiculous but yeah I'm bummed
man I was gonna fly bad I don't know if
they do in a memorial form or something
but I was gonna get I've gotta be in LA
and fortunately it's thing about but you
know I mean this is what happens is any
good friend of yours died me me call it
wasn't like a insanely good friend but I
really did like I'm with mmm what about
Eddie but good friend of yours ever died
no I'm not yet known about you Ben yeah
I wish that for you both of you you know
will be me probably the only some the
only somewhat the only somewhat
successful person either one of you have
ever really met everybody else is just a
complete loser you just go back to
sitting on the porch getting mad at
people with 300 Twitter followers it's
ridiculous
but it is a [__] it is a wake-up call
man it's a wake-up call it should be a
wake-up call where you're just like but
he really did understand that not that's
what food is dude food is a [__] drug
I mean you're sitting in a fast food
place you open up this hot warm salty
fatty sugar you know and you you open it
up and you just go this is this is
something nice I've worked a hellish job
it suck and I'm just gonna have this one
thing that tastes good I just wanna have
this one [__] thing right now that
tastes good you know so I could feel
full and I can go to bed and I don't
have to think about you know yeah I just
want to really it's such a small amount
of time to like that we we give for like
food it's just a nice taste for three
four minutes so you know I mean like
it's like that long of a thing to
indulge in but we just it's it's we love
it for a lot of people man it's the only
indulgence yeah you know you're not on
your boat yeah they're not on the boat :
this is nice you get a few minutes a day
at lunch now when they get out of work
you know yeah I almost never look at
food is like fuel I just want it I just
want something fun you know yeah I mean
that's that's that's a lot of us man
especially when I stopped drinking I
started getting really into like dessert
I never cared about dessert I always
wanted to leave the restaurant go to a
bar right I didn't care then you stopped
drinking you're like oh I'll have all
the desserts because I just want to eat
you know eat sugar now you know you
gotta train yourself man and it's
[__] sucks you know especially when
you were raised with the attitudes
towards food I was raised with which was
raised by two people that exemplified
the group of people the boomers who
everything was convenience and what was
easy and if it was easy to just get a
pizza from Pizza Hut or get fast food on
the way back like and and listen you
know in defense of them they had jobs
they had you
now all right it is what it is they
[__] you know but you know when
you're raised to it I was raised I mean
these are the rest like these are the
places that I ain't growing up okay did
I and I can remember them I can remember
all of them that I would eat like I
would consider somewhat frequently
McDonald's McDonald's is one of my
earliest memories for a lot of people
dude for a lot of people one of your
earliest memories is it you're eating
McDonald's it's good and you like it and
then you ask your parents to go back
they got the play place and they're all
the characters are fun and you're in
McDonald's McDonald's when I was a kid
Boston Market when I was a kid I loved
Boston Market Kentucky Fried Chicken
when I was a kid what the Boston Market
one day I used to come in after dance
class and I had this like and I was like
squeezing this leotard and I was like
just like newly fat body squeezed and
like this purple and black leotard that
made me look try to look like a hip-hop
DJ uh-huh and I was standing there and I
used to sneak it you get two sides when
you got your chair hey am I using it ham
and I would sneak a third side on which
was cinnamon apples but the way I snuck
it on as I'd say put it on the ham and
then the woman would put it on the ham
move it off I actually put it on the ham
then I would get the beans in the mac
and cheese but I said hey put the apples
on the half this is a way that you would
get a third side yeah in Boston Market
so I remember I remember standing there
and I was in with my you know just
dressed like a hip-hop DJ with my
midriff my little gut sticking out of my
midriff and there was a new woman there
and she like barely spoke English and I
said I want to see him in a pose but put
it on the ham and she didn't she put it
in one of the things and I I just I just
I'd had a very grueling day at dance
where I'd fallen a bunch of times so I
was like almost bursting into tears and
I just started screaming put it on the
hair
what the [__] is wrong with you put it
on the ham and the two african guys in
back of her that we're carving the
chickens started chanting put it on Dom
Dom DOM and I was like screaming and
crying and then this lady started crying
she cuz she didn't know what was
happening and then the woman who's a
manager always like a middle-aged white
woman with glasses she came over and I
explained to her and she was we usually
we would charge extra for that but you
know we'll do it we'll just put some
cinnamon apples on the ham it's not a
big deal and I was like thank you but
now no matter what I do like whether
it's a Netflix special I always stand
before I go onstage whether it's Comedy
Central whether it's you know rogue but
it's something important I just I I
always say put it on the ham [__]
before I do I'm kidding I don't but this
next excerpt is from bonus episode 7
Beverly Hills Cop where me and Tim were
just driving around in my toyota up
through the hills of Beverly Hills
making our way to North Beverly Park and
Tim is just talking about dark money and
epstein and he's sort of getting back
into the role of being a tour guide
which I really love this is a really
long episode this is a 20-minute part
from it I found super fascinating this
is really really wealthy a lot of these
houses they start around five million
and then they climb pretty quickly into
the 20s and 30s you know and then even
you know there are estates in Beverly
Hills that are 75 million 80 million 100
million and I think there's a house for
the market in LA and I think it's
perfectly Hills for a hundred and
seventy five million and you know the
person who owns that is guidance
counselor and she just believed in her
kids and that's how she made that kind
of money you know know know people ask
you about this kind of money they're
like where does this kind of money come
from does it come from lawyers and
doctors and the professional class
account and stuff like that not really
this isn't really even CEOs or companies
unless they're large major
to Nationals the reality here is the
majority of people that are not in the
entertainment business are in finance or
they're in tech or they're in the
extraction of Natural Resources they
work at an energy company or they work
in some you know I mean most of the war
money is in and around Maryland in
Virginia and DC which is why the you
know the top 10 wealthiest counties I
think eight of them are right there but
some of those [__] live out here
chill don't kid yourself some of these
[__] live right out here but that's
what people are doing to make that kind
of money there's not too many lawyers up
here with 30 or 40 million dollar houses
unless they're in the top you know 0.001
percent of all lawyers you know so the
professional class of people did it kind
of most people are familiar with don't
live up here a lot of this is foreign
money it's inherited money it's
descendants of royalty tack on a very
high level CEOs of companies that are
major corporations major multinationals
or you have people that have private
companies that you've never heard of
that make doodles of money also you
might potentially have obviously actors
actresses sports people and this is an
interesting one been the black house
nothing satanic going on there they
answer the door every day they're like
Satan's all hello we just passed a solid
black house in Beverly Hills nothing
Goods happening in that basement folks
tell you that much and as you walk your
obvious you see there are people
polishing cars and some of these houses
are actually not impressive right here
these are some not impressed you know
some of them are nice but we're heading
up into an area that's completely gated
where we will be asked to leave and turn
around because these people do not want
people like me we are driving right now
and Benz what is this it's an Avalon it
looks like an uber that's a nice Avalon
it's relatively new how old is it 2008
it's not new at all
I'm disgusted I'm in this car now that I
found that out and I'm sitting in the
front seat with a microphone and where
we're heading up and
starting to get a little bigger they
were bigger on the as you go up the hill
the houses get a little smaller they're
bigger down by the base and then they're
big once you get to the top of the hill
but as you go up the hill the houses are
not nearly as impressive I imagine these
people are like the middle class they
make five to ten million a year you know
which is the middle class I don't think
they make much less than five a year
maybe they do maybe some of these people
do make less than five million dollars a
year but once you get up into two go
[__] your mother money section these are
people who are making you know I
remember I told people that you know
David Tepper who's a hedge fund manager
he bought all the stocks financials he
bought all those up with his hedge fund
when they cratered in 2007 he sold them
or bought in 2008 whatever he sold him
in 2013 his hedge fund made 7.5 billion
his personal income that year was 3.5
billion there our hedge fund guys had
make 800 million a year 300 million a
year you know what I mean and I think
that's what people don't realize you
feel in your ears when you're going up
the hill don't you Ben so the amount of
money that is made I think is
unfathomable Chris Rock said once he
goes if people knew how rich people were
there'd be a riot which is true like the
amount of money when you get up here is
crazy and then you'd have to look up
these people you'd have to google these
people how do they make this kind of
[__] money and I got on this kick
when I was a tour guide in New York City
and I would show people a building I
look at the average price of the
building I mean the average price of the
apartment in the building it would be
like 20 million dollars I'd be like well
what the [__] do these people do who are
they and then you'd learn really crazy
[__] like there was this woman Louise
crane that lived in one of these
buildings I think it was 8:30 for 8 25th
Avenue she lived she her family sold the
paper to the mint that our money was
printed on that our currency was printed
on this [__] own money so now we are
here at the top of the hill we're at
Beverly Park the gate houses
let's do south oh these are the gate
houses to get up into Beverly Park this
is the most expensive section of the
country other than of course Sagaponack
in the Hamptons perhaps you've heard of
it New York shout out to New York and
people that also hate me there
people that want nothing to do but I
have that hometown pride even though
those people would kill me so now we're
gonna have to turn around Benjamin we go
right to the gatehouse Benjamin see the
gates we're right up here at the
gatehouse look at the view Benjamin look
at all the houses Ben grew up in Texas
and a bag of Fritos and it's very nice
from to see this it's very inspiring for
him because he grew up in a house where
they just ate bloody meat and they were
like Jesus Saves
if Jesus can't you Durkin off he gonna
kill you and Ben was like I'm sorry
mother he was British I'm sorry mother
you see some of the houses Ben you see
them that is the Beverly Park over there
that's North Beverly Park let's go up to
the gatehouse up here up here right at
the understand you see Joe and the
reality is the idea that I'm not
welcomed into these communities is
frankly disgusting it's frankly
disgusting because I've done nothing but
entertain for free so rolls-royce
phantom Bentley's now it's getting
banana now it's getting bananas it's
getting stupid now stupid this is stupid
money so now we're getting into some
houses they're like [__] you
Benjamin you got to go back down that
street cuz that was to the gatehouse we
got to go to the gatehouse we got to go
to the gate make them tell us no
Benjamin don't don't be poor you rich
[__] seeing that the Antwoord saw him
rich [__] I'm a rich [__] but that's
the thing about this type of money it's
actually fascinating to start looking up
we're gonna do more of that [__] on the
patreon where we'll actually talk about
some of these people it is kind of
fascinating and interesting how much
money and how much power certain people
have which why I think I got like
Sanders would be good to shake the tree
a little I don't know how much shaking
the tree would matter and I think if
Bernie shook the tree it might land on
him you know a lot of people shake the
tree so now it's not a through Street
but that's okay
violators will be prosecuted trespassing
doesn't matter Benjamin keep going have
balls now we are in the most exclusive
area in the country right now folks
North Beverly Park
keep going bad don't be a [__] here's
the gate the gate stops as I thought
we're gonna get in Ben now just make the
UE I thought we were gonna get in gated
community but look at the house right
behind the gate here
I mean Disney World you see it up in the
tree you can barely say it you can't say
it yeah it's wild did I mean it's wild
they do not let you in here and that's
okay but you could see them over there
the houses the homes these are massive
estates folks these are massive and you
know I mean I've been kept out of these
communities I've been denied I've been
literally [__] on my whole life people
just open they open my mouth and they
[__] directly into my mouth and I have
to swallow that [__] for many many years
and all I all I've tried to do is go
into wealthy areas now what I will do
and Ben will tell you this I will walk
around in wealthier ease without case I
get a cup of coffee and I and I wear
like sweatpants to look like I just woke
up and I'll just walk around these areas
like Hancock Park that are rich that
don't have gates I guarantee there are
areas that will have gates in California
in three years because of me the
residents will get together and go get
that fat [__] out of here we're putting
up a game guaranteed folks
guaran-fucking-tee it's a beautiful fall
day here if I could do it all over again
I'd just be rich as [__] and I'd kill
people I wish I was [__] just crazy
rich but instead I'm a creative genius
[__] now we're we're in a coldest sack
and it's a dead end
there are several Mexicans and they're
all looking at me and benches they know
that we're not the type of white that
belongs here
a lot of construction going on here and
listed these areas are over built New
York City's over built there's too much
high-end [__] on the market there's not
enough foreign money to pump into these
markets you will see you know values
decline to a degree in these areas
because you know especially once we head
into the recession but you've already
seen wealthy people are starting to
hoard cash because they know what's
coming they know before us what's gonna
happen because they make it happen
through the gray show they're already
starting to hoard money and not buy
these homes but you got to remember one
of the real reasons that New York City
real estate market did not suffer during
the financial crisis is that domestic
money was replaced by foreign money and
foreign people came over to America and
they wanted to move their money out of
Russia and China and the United Arab
Emirates and Brazil and India and they
wanted to buy homes in New York and
London and also Los Angeles to a degree
to a lesser degree and you know London
is a great financial capital that's
halfway between New York and Asia so
London is number one
London is number one with foreign money
60 to 70% of all new construction in
London is is it is was at one time and
I'm sure it still hovers around that
percentage now going to people that do
not live in Britain they are not you
know they might have citizenship but the
majority has a lot of them are foreign
nationals without citizenship and it's
not their primary residence and they're
buying up snatching up lots of real
estate there New York is second there's
a lot of people buying in New York you
get rid great return on your investment
in a city like New York and London you
could let it sit vacant and it'll just
appreciate it value if you buy an
apartment you could also rent it out and
you get a lot of money and none of these
people are buying it under their own
name they're buying it under the name of
a shell Corp which is a corporation that
is set up really primarily to invest in
real estate also private companies but a
lot of times it's real
stay and what people why do people use a
shell Corp so that they are not on the
hook for taxes that they can kind of
launder money in these cities through
real estate and the extent to which real
estate is used for money laundering is
pretty well-known but it's only
intensified over the last decade slowed
down a little bit now but you want to
talk about you know how crazy it was
going you know right after the financial
crisis people came over here and just
started buying buying buying and that's
where you get into like things like the
Panama papers and the person that
released the Panama papers is now dead I
forget how probably a bad called and the
Panama papers were an explanation of
this of this other financial system that
wealthy people had set out for
themselves where they put their money
offshore and you know the New York Times
to their credit actually read a great
article that was pretty complicated that
very few people read that was about how
people especially wealthy people route
their money through companies that don't
exist so that they can pay corporate tax
rates and these companies don't exist
and they have you know they have
addresses but there's there's no
employees and there's no offices and
there's no they they just exist simply
to kind of clear money they're like a
clearinghouse of money I'll post some of
these articles on the patreon because I
would imagine some of the people that
are listening to this are a little
smarter than the regular people we got
we're over a hundred thousand downloads
on the episode now so there's a lot of
different kinds of people listening to
show they're in all kinds of different
[__] you people are probably a little
bit smarter now not all of you not all
of you I will let rain that in let's
roll that back there's many people here
that are not but there are a few people
that want to read some of these articles
so we will post them it's a great
article it's a dense article it's a long
article but you start to look at what
what a separate financial system looks
like because it's really completely
separate for people at a certain net
worth and I think it a certain net worth
you just start to spend time with people
to just kind of piss in your ear I'm not
even talking about people that are
making 5 million a year I'm talking
about serious money
generational wealth where where this is
just the way things are done and and
there's all kinds of people that make
money showing you how to shield yourself
from taxes and accountability and and
and guys like I forget his name I think
it's a neat Agarwal aggarwal is his last
name I forget his first name who bought
an apartment at the Time Warner Center
this is a very controversial mining
magnate who like poison to river and
Zambia and he so what you have you see
two girls there at standing front of a
pink house with pink hair is that Dozier
cat we're hunting for Dozier cat we want
to find the cat what do you think she
isn't jollibee but what the whole thing
is I want to flesh out some of this
stuff because this is by the way this is
the key to Epstein this is the key taps
team and I want you to start thinking
about this in a more broader context
than just pedophiles and Satanism and
human sacrifice which by the way all
probably happening why did you stay
there Benjamin been stayed oh that's
where which isin used to live Ben is one
of the slaves for the Aisin family and
was for many years good for him
this is what I want you to think about
Epstein in a more broad context of human
trafficking obviously paedophile
blackmail obviously but what Epstein did
I think and from from people that are
that from when you where boy I spoke to
who's done a lot of great work on it and
from a lot of people that I spoke to
both on and off the record they believe
Jeffries main other than the blackmail
and all of that stuff they believe one
of his main functions was washing dirty
money laundering money okay um it wasn't
only the type of money that would be
earned from human trafficking but you're
looking at narco-terrorism drugs
you're looking at god only knows the
kind of corporate malfeasance he was
tasked with making go away or cleaning
up in the financial system finding
places to put the money finding places
for the money to go you got to remember
Lex west or less wax know who's Jeffrey
Epstein's mentor and good friend and
gave him his mansion in New York City
and gave him les Wexner was questioned
his attorney or accountant I think his
accountant was going to testify about
off shoring profits who's gonna testify
about offshoring money and he was shot
in the face before he's able to do that
he was killed in broad daylight in a
mafia style hit so this issue cuts right
to the core of what we're talking about
so it's like we're driving around
Beverly Hills and you're like well how
does that connect to everything well it
connects to everything actually it is
everything it actually is the core of
everything because there isn't one
only one illicit stream of money there
are many illicit streams of money that
are not accounted for that are not taxed
the CIA uses illicit money black-budget
all the time because they do things that
they don't want to sorry Bryan Callen
they do things that they don't want the
Senate Intelligence Committee to know
about that's why they bugged the Senate
Intelligence Committee that's why
they've admitted to spying on the Senate
Intelligence Committee because they
don't want the Senate Intelligence
Committee to know what they're doing so
they want to know what the Senate
Intelligence Committee knows because
they do underground activities the CIA
so when you talk about the illicit
streams of money that guys like Jeffrey
Epstein direct and manage and you look
at the amount of people not all of the
pedophiles some of them just regular
crooks
regular old crooks and so then it gets
very messy right so now you're took a
bit Epstein right so let's say we talk
about like well what happens if Jeffrey
goes in and sinks is it just people that
have been to his island that go down
or does he hold the key to a lot of
nefarious activities and a lot of
bold-faced names and a lot of powerful
people that are beyond the scope of even
that island you know what I mean and I
think the reason that you can't let
Jeffrey Singh obviously you can't let
him talk about politicians diddling
children on an island that is no good
that is a problem but the other reason
is because I don't think the press can
truly get a whiff of how insanely
corrupt the financial system is how many
people are benefiting from it and the
role of guys like Jeffrey Epstein or
kind of these Cowboys that are somewhat
rootless he blows around the globe he's
friends with everybody's friends of
Mohammed bin Salman in Saudi Arabia
he's friends with political leaders in
the United States and yes a lot of it is
probably the you know pedophilia and
stuff like that because I realize it's
pretty nobody's a pedophile that's also
refute like nobody's a pedophile but
doesn't cheat on their taxes is what I
mean like if you're doing that you're
probably open to drugs and cheating in
any way that you can you know and
illegal arms dealing that's why he's
friends with Qaddafi and you know
nagashi this huge arms dealer Epstein
was good friends with too so there's
this whole underground economy where you
have illicit streams of money you have
capital that needs to find a home and
you have guys like Jeffrey Epstein so as
much as it is about this island and it
is about the appetites of the wealthy
enough these people are getting out of
control cuz now we're back down in the
area where you have you know some of the
poor here and yet I mean poor be meaning
BMWs like three and five series no good
very aggressive
they're striving two climbers they're
trying to get to the top of the hill and
they're there in a rush people at the
top of the hill aren't even a rush
they're not even home they don't even
exist go to a rich area you never see
the people
because they maintain multiple
properties there's somewhere else here's
a couple of just nice autistic brothers
walking around counting blades of grass
God love him jumping - bonus episode 26
steyr Stan and this segment tim talks
about the healthcare industry and what
we have to do to actually get people to
be healthy in this country this is why
i'm literally this is me now I'm gonna
run I'm gonna run Ben and I want you to
ask me questions that you hear people
asking I'm gonna give you my real
answers I'm on the stage I'm I'm running
Tim Dylan is now running for the
Presidency of America I want you to ask
me real questions okay Tim Dylan what is
your proposal for our immigration policy
that we have right now in America here's
a reality of the situation folks there's
a lot of boomers that are retiring
somebody's gonna need to wipe their ass
we're gonna shove them into assisted
living facilities hopefully immediately
hopefully by force we're gonna need
people to go in there drug these boomers
up they're gonna be drooling and
[__] all over the place and we're
gonna need somebody to do it I don't
really want to do it many of my lazy
friends are probably not going to do it
either so we need some immigrants to
just chain my parents and your parents
to their beds so that they can piss and
[__] themselves until they die now that
being said we can't let everybody in
because that would break the economy so
what we're gonna have to do is we're
gonna bring immigrants in that have the
skillset to chain my aunt Kathleen to a
chair and an assisted living facility
and be her we're gonna give them on
Facebook we give them on Facebook and
let them scream into the void so we need
some immigrants we don't we but we can't
have everybody next question what is
your plan with with health care in
America it's a real ongoing issue a lot
of people aren't covered they're in
medical debt how do you seek to rectify
this whole situation here's what we're
gonna do with health care here's what
we're gonna do with health care we're
going to
here's what you really have to do by the
way yeah this is what people don't want
to hear you're gonna have to like outlaw
Denny's and IHOP and Carl's jr. you're
gonna have to put the military around
calls junior and up like actually dead
serious now you're gonna have to put
people with guns outside of Popeyes and
calls Junior you're gonna have to outlaw
like buffets you're gonna have to outlaw
breakfast cereals that literally deliver
more sugar to the brain of a child than
they should have in their entire
existence in a sitting
um like we could give you free
healthcare folks and you should get it
health care should be a right but I mean
if we don't you know we're gonna have to
just go in there and we're gonna have to
tell people that they have to stop with
the food and the booze I mean I don't
know that anybody wants to hear this
you're gonna have to get like up you're
gonna have to get like a card where you
get to go out to eat you get to go out
to eat like it's we're gonna have to run
the country like Weight Watchers except
it's gonna have to be enforced by the
prison system like if you go over your
points we're gonna have to put you in
jail like if you if you go over your
point to Weight Watchers we're gonna
have to have a Stasi like police force
drag you out of your house and throw you
in prison because all the health care in
the world is not gonna work when Denny's
is slinging salted caramel banana cream
french toast to 400-pound people in San
Antonio it's just not gonna work
literally every themed restaurant in the
country is trying to kill everyone that
lives here at literally every single I
mean the menu would get get the menu get
up the menu at Denny's
just get up the menu at Denny's like
this is the real nobody will do this by
the way on stage like nobody will go
let's take a look I want that candidate
who goes yeah oh great yeah health
carrots that's all
bad but let's look at the menu at
America's diner quote their words
America's diner let's see what we have
you want to see featured items first um
let's go to fluffy pancakes how we start
our day this is how America starts our
dad this is how we start the day please
read us some of the offerings Benjamin
classic tres leges pancakes tres leches
pancakes cinnamon roll pancake breakfast
salted caramel and banana cream pancake
breakfast that doesn't even sound good
by the way go-to salted caramel banana
cream pancake breakfast let's view the
item now buttermilk pancakes now read
this by the way in Europe like this
would be illegal and people would be
sent to jail if they would firebomb a
restaurant to try to serve this by the
way it's almost hilarious discussing
health care and leaving out all of this
right let's read the description of the
item buttermilk pancakes cooked with
shortbread pieces and topped with
vanilla cream banana and even more
shortbread pieces by the way that is
literally their quote serve with a
picture of warm the picture of warm
salted caramel for drizzling serve with
2 X 2 X 2 eggs hash browns plus 2 bacon
strips or two sausage links and I bet
you could turn that or into an and
nutritional facts how many calories
Benjamin fourteen hundred and thirty
calories okay let's look at something
else let's look at something else let's
go to the double berry banana pancake
breakfast because this looks good as
[__] buttermilk pancakes cooked with
blueberries atop with fresh seasonal
berries bananas and whipped cream served
with two eggs hash browns two bacon
strips
okay this is their healthy meal it's
only a thousand calories how much does
the cinnamon roll breakfast clocking in
at eighteen ten eighteen ten let's see
what eighteen hundred and ten calories
buttermilk pancakes cooked with cinnamon
crumb topping and topped with
serve with a picture of warm cream
cheese
serve with a picture of war cream cheese
icing for drizzling plus UX resume guys
what health care let's be honest what
health care program is going to compete
with America's diner eighteen hundred
cinnamon roll pancake everybody in this
country should be forced to smoke
cigarettes in a health initiative right
now there should be a health initiative
called light up if it if it even saves
your appetite offer minute now go to the
grand slam which Benjamin find the ps/2
resistance the Grand Slam but the Grand
Slam which by the way this is a bigger
threat to our country than terrorism has
ever been has ever been let's find the
grand slam which the grand slam which is
my favorite so it might not be in super
sandwiches it's not there
oh it's not a super sandwiches no maybe
featured items classic breakfast faves
go to classic breakfast faves right
there yeah I think we're good I think
we're getting to the yep now go to the
grand slam which what do we got here
eleven and fifty calories just listen to
this folks listen to this by the way it
looks like someone vomited on bread
scrambled eggs
this is my favorite scrambled egg
sausage bacon ham American cheese on
potato bread grilled with a maple spice
spread served with hash browns so here's
the thing with health care I mean folks
well what are we doing like Denny's I
hop go to Carl's jr. Google Carl's jr.
you want to go to health care like it
it's one thing it's an immoral health
care system but I mean I hate to say it
but we're gonna need to put the military
outside of Carl's jr. let's see the
different burger options cuz I think one
of them has five four or five patties on
okay all right
see sorry it's a little we have a little
traffic here we're sitting out on the
the new porch let's look at the Western
bacon cheeseburger what are we looking
at on the Western bacon burger
did they give you calorie counts no this
the thing isn't loading on their website
here that's convenient this rep website
is run by acronym that brought you
shadow oh here I got it now you have to
add the item okay but go find the one
that has five patties or whatever it is
the big Carl or they're really it's the
really big odor a really big Carl how
many patties on the really big car this
one's got three three patties on the
really big Carl movie add it to my cart
add the really big Carl to the car okay
this is great how do you add it again i
this one is not letting me add it here's
what I think people need to realize here
it's like people talk about like the
weapons industry and the pharmaceutical
industry but the food industry like fast
food and fast casual food now many
people know about me that I called Tim
your fat fine Steakhouse fat that's
still bad still bad I'm not called jr.
fat like I didn't get fat it calls
Junior I got fat if you come to my live
show you'll will do we talk about
Wendy's you talk about the hot but I
mean this is the problem with health
care it's like this is and dude fergus
show duh forget that I don't drink so
I've never drank anything with bubbles I
just don't like carbonation but think
about the amount of people that are
eating this food day in and day out you
know it's just it's kind of a nightmare
and I'm a freedom guy I want everyone to
have freedom but at what point do you
say and for all on it if we're all on a
program right like if we're all on a
health care program a public option
at what point do you say like you can't
go out and have a big Karl every day at
lunch you can't have a big Karl should
there be a card that you go to use and
they've gone up you've had two big
Karl's you've already had two big Carl
and a really big Karl yeah you've had a
really big Karl yesterday you had a
really big Karl today you came in here
to have a big car like you it's you
can't do it you can't eat tres leches
pancakes
in the morning you know go to the
unhealthiest items in America I mean the
Cheesecake Factory got a bunch I mean we
won't do the whole episode talking about
this but like there is just this idea
that personal responsibility is
completely vanished from like anything
and that nobody's responsible for
anything
yeah let's read some of the okay 15
highest calorie restaurant meals Buffalo
Wild Wings we got at 15 the cheese curd
bacon burger dude that's vomit-inducing
Jesus dude cheese curds are disgusting
I'm sorry if you're from that frozen
tundra Wisconsin with all those [__]
but they're disgusting and they put it
deep fried cheese curds on top of a
bacon cheeseburger 2,000 calories I mean
dude it's not even good I loved Outback
Steakhouse herb-roasted prime rib is
next look at that big fat slab my mother
loves that 2,400 cows i hot cheese
burger omelet with pancakes I mean if
you go to another country and you showed
them this food literally if you sat down
with someone and in Belgium if someone
started to make this food like this is
why Asia is getting factors they're now
getting our fast food and you're seeing
like fat Asians for the first time but
like other European countries everyone
talks about these socialist countries
like Denmark and Norway here's what
they're not doing they're not slinging
cheeseburger omelets and tres leches
pancakes to the population
the weight for a very like low price
this is not expensive no you can go in
and kill yourself $9.00 Shake Shack keep
going down listen to the Sonics
pineapple upside-down master blast shake
I'm by the way gross vanilla ice cream
pineapple salted caramel and pie crust
pieces this is the thing folks it's this
is not even good it doesn't taste good
but that's what I think people that I
guess people just so upset and they
don't realize that literally you're
ingesting poison that isn't even
enjoyable it's a literal drug and dave
and buster's carnivore Pizza dia it
doesn't it sounds like an attack it
doesn't even sound like food 2,000
calories a giant quesadilla stuff with
Manchego cheddar cheese pepperoni
sausage smothered a more cheese
pepperoni sausage me and Ben were in
Vegas and we walked past the Heart
Attack Grill which is where people die
while eating there and they're proud of
it and you're looking at people sitting
in this place eating butter fat
milkshakes and like six patty burgers
and it's like it's become as big of a
problem as the opioid crisis now it's
not as expensive as heroin so no one's
killing you no one's stabbing you in the
street to go get tres leches pancakes
but you remember when Michelle oh my
Christine funny comic out of New York
had a great joke about this he's like
remember when Michelle Obama's like we
should all eat salads and then want one
fat white one most like but I feel
beautiful the way I am and we're like
alright yeah [__] the salad initiative
lena Dunham's like no but I'm booty-ful
everyone's like okay you're right
everyone gets so mad at Michelle Obama
was trying to feed kids broccoli
remember that people like she's a
communist she's trying to make these
kids because she just didn't want like
people eating whoppers for lunch bonus
episode 27 live from Toronto this was
recorded last week Tim and the great
Raymond calm
perform the podcast live I hope you
enjoyed this segment I mean would you
prefer royalty to what we have in
America now I mean what do we what would
you even call what we have
it's like rape boils here or something
yeah I mean what we have now is just
caught as close to professional
wrestling yeah as it's ever been
I mean it's it's pretty just people
hitting each other with chairs up there
right I mean how great would be though
it's like we had to like literally put a
crown on Trump yeah I mean that's yeah
that would be fun what people don't get
us it's like it is the ruling class it's
just losing power
yeah and it is wild to watch like they
don't know what that you Michael
Bloomberg's trying to buy the electors
they don't know what to do anymore
there's you're spending all this money
they don't know what to do there's
nothing to do I don't know what people
think is gonna like this is [__] over
the Chinese are taking over like and
like white man can't not that [__] I'm
just saying we've been scamming
everything for 200 years now it's done
you had it we had a run we had a good
run we had a nice run balance the books
it's like like I had a kid last night in
the show
he's like I'm majoring in social work
I'm like what are you you're gonna help
what are you doing with that like Social
Work wait so it's really putting people
to mass graves yeah I don't even know
what it is
yeah it's not it's some kid getting
burned with cigarettes and you walk in
we would just mean you would make it so
much worse the kid a minute my parents
hit me we're like didn't even you're
whining about your parents heroin addict
me like let's do your taxes poison yeah
cuz that is what Social Work is it's
like some junkie is like the Dutch
questionnaires yeah good let's do a
questionnaire what would you like where
they have to sit down and be like what
do you want to accomplish in this
program
really itchy right now would you like to
accomplish in this program sir it's you
know listen you know we we we kid but
you know God love everyone and it's a
real problem out there it's a real
problem
Trump will probably win again you know
I'd imagine he would what Bernie Sanders
as a messianic thing going on and he's
good we like Bernie I don't think we'll
get anything done but that is fault yeah
just what's what it is like ideal it's
what it is I mean super which what where
we live I don't understand about the
left is that you have it's like there's
gonna start the install the deeps
whatever the [__] you call you
loominatee they start wars whenever the
[__] they feel like it and you're trying
to give away your assault rifles right
like what I understand I'm seeing like
resist on Twitter yeah resist wrote
Bernie it's like they get who are you
resisting with a [__] sweet we're
[__] like a few people right that's
what we're saying I got a [__]
dustpan we hit you with it like no but
the other problem is that all the
pro-gun knots say they don't want to
give up their guns because they're like
well it's if the government gets
tyrannical it's like it's tyrannical now
you're gonna shoot anyone start now this
is an entertainment show all shows
entertainment it's an entertaining show
it's entertainment it's not the only
read about home defense
I think shouldn't be able to have a gun
for home defense I want you to be
elevated and be cocked in a weird
scenario I don't care about that but I
do I do like the idea of like
overthrowing a government I think it's
nice at least in America I mean I know
you guys feel about it but like that's
how we were raised nobody's gonna do
that in America except what's to fact
exactly and the only people who are
doing it or like defending racist
statues right we look malicious yes the
only thing they care about is racist at
the Robert Lee stache
like you can [__] our kids but don't
touch that robert e lee statue
don't you dare that's our heritage
that's our goddamn history bill just
Barcia for like healthcare yeah they
would let him keep the guns it's so true
they never bring the guns out for
anything good yeah they're never like
clean up the planet with the guns they
never marched around with ak-47s you
Beyonce a Grammy yeah
she deserves it
what about the state of popular culture
and music I mean it's you were making
electronic music now many people don't
know this oh yeah I mean I dabble with
it I'm not you know that reminds me
when's Diana died I was listening to
techno music on a radio see the bridges
is dead and they just are back into like
the princess is dead did you see
yourself becoming a DJ like Skrillex I
need to find maybe I mean the mouse head
Armin van Buuren I don't know these
people
Steve Aoki that dia you know the guy who
looks like a wizard I feel like I have
this vision of me like DJ and like I'm
dressed like a baby and how do I dress
how do you dress like a baby diaper and
just say you're in a diaper to set up
where I'm like in the crib but I'm
spinning records I gotta be honest with
you this sounds amazing that's the thing
where if that was happening in LA I'm
not even kidding if you walked in cuz la
showed knots and everyone's on so many
drugs that if they if they just saw you
in a big cage doing that people be like
yo that's baby comp that's DJ baby calm
like [__] really man whoa did that guy
with the rat head yeah with deadmau5 or
whatever he's rich
yeah he is rich
so yeah I mean but the state of music
today I mean it just seems like
Gregorian chant for like molesting
children is like that's really bad I
wanna [__] your dad and suck on his tits
use me like a toilet and then like I'm
your toilet
would you like to OSHA cata look the
OSHA cat is just like the whole thing
crashing yeah it's like the simulation
just being like it's a good song that
juicy song keep it juicy Jersey do we
have the ability here to play music no
no good phenomenal so just out of
curiosity I knew the answer but I was
gonna treat everyone to a song but
anyway I don't wanna be the old fogey or
whatever is that offensive hello don't
worry he bites I'm a photographer
oh yeah there was that I'm scared I'm a
photographer you want me to show you how
to take a pretty face I use the
photograph weddings and bar mitzvahs
sweet 16 everything anything one what
mixers are great will you into somatic
all right
[Applause]
not mutually exclusive plenty of
self-hating Jews we found a self-hating
Jew and I love all because she doesn't
want to photograph apartments is which
no one wants to run around a party and
photograph I'm not over a woman a Bar
Mitzvah why now yeah so anyway I don't
know being like yeah what's her name
again
Billie Eilish Billie Eilish she's no
Whitney Houston no wouldn't use it was
maybe the greatest singer of our time
right and you still end up getting a tub
you'll never not die in a tub that's the
point you go to Hollywood with all these
big ideas you die in a tub if you're
lucky we don't want like there's no
aspirational art anymore no we don't
want that we want like somebody that we
could do it
I want like some amazing night amazing
so I want something decent that randomly
came out of a dying cancer patients like
yeah notebook right and then like that
guy's also a junkie
I'm doing fine yeah yeah that's what no
one wants to be like oh I have to like
spend ten years like doing vocal lessons
was like even Liz Oh who's good but
she's not great no she's not like look
marking and Carrie she's fat but like
it's the whole thing look how proud of
her bat boy she is she's a gem and like
I don't care but like give it like no
one's like what is this for like what is
this they're trying to keep us as like
cattle or something like fat cattle yeah
government wants me to be fat yes and
like wants me that rotten teeth that's
why they [__] made me drink diet coke
every day Liz was gonna have a song soon
my teeth are rotting
do you have dental Samman I want to
perform my own operation on my to why my
teeth are [__]
[Music]
what is a good thing to get that we
cannot get in America what no booty in
here what'd you say
well here's the thing guys usually thing
with the poutine I'm not getting it at
McDonald's I mean that seems [__] up
yeah Montreal yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
that's the other festival that's not in
the homeless shelter wait wait is
poutine like french fries with cabbage
french fries cheese curds and like gravy
it's pretty good it's not what else is
her on - known for a lot of
middle-eastern food right snake they
have a lot of steak houses here oh you
have a lot of steak here nice well done
steak [__] you yeah yeah you here's your
charred beef and don't and you'll put
you jail if you say the wrong thing here
put me in jail for [__] being fat
yeah well they should I just want to be
in a cage yeah he was so excited I'm
like you might go to jail oh good he's
like can we arrange this so that I do go
to jail like I don't want to be used
like a toilet right the greatest part of
that sentence was but you're like I
don't want to be used like a toilet
last but not least bonus episode 8 it's
a vibe this is one of my favorite
moments from any of the patreon episodes
where Tim talks about how easy it is to
be a recording artist and he's just
talking about Billy Eilish and this guy
he met in Houston I just love this
little chunk here enjoy a lot of people
from my high school graduate people seem
to be closer with people they met in
high school in college yes because you
go back I guess to this hometown and
stuff and many of the people that I am
that I was friendly with in high school
don't really talk to anymore they don't
reach out to me they're intimidated by
my fame and I remember the last time I
went back to Long Island I was trying to
get a bagel and I was inundated with
people that wanted pictures with me and
they wanted my autograph and many of
them are trying to [__] me as I walked
in to get a bagel it was just very
annoying and they were just like hey can
I get a pic
[__] you I was like alright fine so I
was on the big line I was just [__]
them and they were taking photos with me
like selfies it was just awkward but
listen I get it it's nice when someone
you know ends up being a famous star
like me or Billy
Eilish Satan is my father in the night
he comes in my room and he gives me a
baby and when the baby is born it will
enslave the world and Jimmy Fallon's
like that's great you're such a talent
I'd hug you but I'm chained to my desk
we don't want another incident you know
that's all I'm saying folks I don't know
how to tell you how to live just go to
if you're a kid you want to go away to
school go away to school have some fun
out there enjoy yourself you know go
away go somewhere different I've only
lived in New York or LA I've only lived
in New York or Los Angeles you know it's
crazy to think about and I'll probably
never live anywhere else you know I
can't envision baby when I'm older I'll
move somewhere else I think about that
often but these are the only two places
I've lived it's very unhealthy to very
unhealthy environments you know but
they're really the only two places that
I can do what I do you know which is
inspire people all over the world to
really live I I got a message other day
from a child in India who watches the
show he's four and he said Tim Tim Tim I
don't know I can't do an accent stop I
just got it's not that I'm against it I
just can't even guys I'm so bad at it
why is it why is it it's not I don't I'm
not
respecting anyone if I do it but I just
smoked a few cigarettes I can't hello he
says four-year-old wrote me a letter he
said Tim he said you know things are not
great here because I live in a slum and
he goes I think I you know you know I I
think that it's very hard to you know we
don't really have Wi-Fi we have one
little computer here in the whole small
village and we all get together and we
watch the show all the villagers will
watch the podcast every week and we they
cancel their subscriptions to guest
digital many of them after I left I
didn't tell them to do that but they did
that because they were they would they
were he goes with eating literal garbage
here we're eating garbage and we're
living in garbage we're living living in
in towns made of garbage but when we
watch your show and you tell us that
it's not gonna get better we get it and
we connect with it and we understand and
it makes sense to us and we laugh
because we laugh because my brother was
eaten by a tiger and he said but
watching you she was kind of smoked
cigarettes on a porch in Los Angeles and
scream made me understand that even
though there probably is no God and we
live in an unending hellscape and
literal demons run this earth in this
reality reptilians from another
dimension
suck joy out of people and then they
feed off negative energy and they use it
to create this paradigm that we will
live in and we can't get out of it we
don't know how the only way to do it is
high doses of psychedelic drugs which I
can't even afford
he goes even though that's all the case
and I know that I think this guy's for
spring even though that's the case he
because I still just get enjoyment from
watching you blow smoke into the Los
Angeles sky that's why I do it that's
why I do it I don't do it I don't do for
the money I'm gonna do for the fame I do
I do it for both I do it really for
those two things it's predominantly why
I do it those are the only two reasons I
do it literally those are literally the
only two reasons that anyone does it
anyone that says you don't do anything
for money or fame is a flyer they're
lying to your face I just do it for the
kids
yeah yeah okay but you know it is one of
my regrets if I had gone to college what
kind of life would I've lived but I've
been a swimmer and good-looking and not
funny then I would have really succeeded
in comedy I'd live in a small little
liberal arts ecology [__] town and
I'd maybe I was still drank smoked a
little weed get in front of a room of
dumb kids and inspire those losers and
say I'm a teacher aren't I cool I'm the
cool teacher maybe I would have been the
cool teacher hey I'm the cool drama
teacher I'm the cool you know I was in
Houston with Christ room and there was a
couple of kids with volunteering I love
cutting kids down it's one of my
favorite things like just just just
looking at him and going you're a fraud
you know I see that the baby sometimes I
look at him I go you're a fraud I'm but
then some babies are like [__] you
[__] and then I'm like interesting I
respect you
there were these Street kids that were
they were volunteering at the theater
and I said what do you guys do they're
like we're in the theater program I said
oh that's good and I said so what
happens like after you graduate you move
to New York or LA and they go no
actually they go no actually uh Houston
got the third-largest arts community in
the country and I just went and I left
in their face and I went guys come on
don't be stupid as soon as I told that
to Bernie laughs I said and they said no
usually got the third largest liberal
arts community Brad the third largest
arts committee and burnt laughs so hard
because you don't have it to go and
[__] get kicked in the face and
there's nothing wrong with that you know
but don't pretend that you're gonna make
some kind of career in [__] Houston
Texas as a theater made can you stop cut
it out I just looked into my left right
in their goddamn faces and I said that's
hit man I was a theater group on my tour
bus one day when I was doing the tours
and they were like yeah some girl that
graduated she moved to New York City now
she thinks she's better than all of us
I'm like she is she is
I went to a Long Island a Holy Trinity
High School that we had one of the best
theater programs we one of the first
high schools and look around do laymen I
wasn't in the theater groups I'm not a
loser I'm in the real theater okay
okay tough guy um and one of the one of
the you know that theater group produced
the best theater group on the map
produced a lot of lawyers because you're
all full of [__] every one of those
theater kids should should have been
made to play gym and made to do what I
did run around a track being chased by a
fire-breathing Dyke and look at penises
while pretending they weren't that would
have been a much better skill set for
them to [__] have then [__] this
fake [__] theater [__] thing then
nobody you should you should sign a
pledge if you get out of gym for four
years that you have to do theater for
ten years and ruin your life you should
be living in a [__] you know in a
[__] dirty apartment New York with no
hot water
going on auditions we [__] clunky ass
trying to dance around and try to do it
Broadway is a hell if you get on
Broadway it's an absolute hell nobody
gives a [__] about you we went to go see
that ferryman show so great nobody gives
a [__] about those people spit on him
right in the street
I love the chef I ever saw one of those
people I would just spit right on him I
[Laughter]
saw that show three times I liked it so
much so good I I Phantom of the Opera
which sucks now it is just it is so bad
now so bad dude he used to be so good
there was a guy who was clearly trying
it no voice and he was like one of the
principals it was like $600 it is like
so expensive and the guys like the guy
was singing he's like people like is
this guy out late last night probably
got a victim he's probably homeless but
that sure I knew the the lady that
played mag in that show who's not the
lead the lead is Christine the other one
is Meg meg I knew she used to sit in the
Food Emporium and drink clam chowder and
stare at the rain every day before she
had to walk into the theater she was a
cat-like woman very pensive startled
easily and you see these people they
just dedicate their lives to theater
like three people succeed my cousin my
third cousin is one of them
Bobby Lopez he wrote the music for
Avenue Q Book of Mormon frozen ze got
winner Emmy Grammy Oscar Tony to to
leach she's one thing he got twice he's
won two Emmys two Grammys to Oscar to
Tony's he's in the most elite crew he
deals like Bob Michael Eisner who's a
guy who owns Bob Iger at Disney I don't
know he deals with those people
personally he said why do I have an
agent
he said what's the think I don't know
why I have w babe will you please people
directly his agent call them watch like
we're gonna get you more work he's more
work what there's no more work
I'm dude frozen - like I'm doing like
guys got money he's like theater royalty
his best friend's lin-manuel Miranda he
kid in my grandma's funeral once I'm
like hey come check out one of my comedy
shows he's like well your grandmother
was a good woman that was it
which is fair I get it it's theater
royalty but there's guys like him his
brother his little brother ended up
getting [__] over he went into like
Nickelodeon or something and they stole
his idea or maybe was Adult Swim I don't
know one of those places maybe who's MTV
or Nickelodeon one of those things he
just went in pinched something and three
months later they started making it
lawyers and everything yeah
do people don't care let's steal your
[__] but most people in theater are
damned so I think if you get out of dice
jam for four years you should have to at
least give it a shot you know it's a
tough profession man it's [__] hard
as [__] it's a very talented people is
very hard to bed idina menzel
became super famous she was that she was
in rant and then in wicked and then it
frozen she became super famous but dude
the amount of people that become super
famous for Broadway it's like three of
them it's very very hard and uh and I
don't care but I don't care it's that's
what it's supposed to be but it's what
it is - calling we believe in its
religious like everything we talked
about but those kids in Houston were
hilarious well actually Houston as a
third largest time you shut the [__] up
you clown pieces of fat one of the
fattest cities in America the only thing
they have the third-largest huff is
people having coronaries at [__]
Arby's you have the third-largest people
in America not the third largest art
scene maybe they view of the third but
it's like that Bill Higgs joke you know
when he goes Iraq at the fourth largest
in the world but yeah after the first
three armies a real drop off after New
York in LA but is a real drop-off in art
scenes Liz Loza ass as the fourth
largest art scene in the country shut
out - Liz I'm clapping with her soon
dosha cat Eilish Liz Oh Dylan that's
much it what if I what if I somehow
became a recording artist you know what
what music would I have to do what kind
of music hmm hip-hop or something
hey that's for the blacks now oh really
I think they want I think that's what
makes it cool is that it's people black
people getting into a genre of music
that hadn't previously been into yeah I
picturing you with big black framed
glasses like FUBU full jumpsuit chains I
really picture you doing it I mean
there's so many people we know that
aren't funny at all that are very
successful as comic yeah most so it's
not layer majora it's not hard for you
imagine a big majority feel the beat can
you get a beat up right now yeah let's
see like a beat where I could be a
recording artist I want to be like close
Maloney though I've been into rockstar
with my [__] I've been in a club with
this ho she be looking at me all night
though I'll be like where you going you
ho she's like I'm gonna go and get to
blow I said maybe we shouldn't do blow
hold on yeah this is where tied you want
to see how easy this to be recording
artist I'll give it to you right now
here we go I pull up in the Bentley
she'd be looking for a long time I
really hard days but I've gotta make the
song run this is ruining it little baby
not hold on I got a vibe with the beat
see me out of sunset all my boys and my
girls in the car everybody like this
isn't even fun yet and I'm like
society's collapsing cuz the corporate
state is owned and us we're living
inverted totalitarianism my boss shall
the rolling corn that term he's dead now
loves him where my HOS at
we might as well be foes now because we
can only come if it's violent we need a
lot of sexual violence our society is
built on war and murder of the innocent
the torture and rape of the innocent and
the murder of children because you know
that killing children and I'll be
chilling in my Rover American Empire is
over
where my home who's that for you home
for the corporate state I am I am spread
my [__]
[Music]
in my mouth he was to survive I mean I
think that's that that's now the
critique of that song would be that it's
it's it's a little too
it's very lyrical it's very lyrical
and but it's a vibe you know
yeah patreon.com slash the Tim Dylan
show please go sign up it's only $5 a
month
there's hundreds of hours of bonus
content on there it's a great way to
support the show also go to Tim Dylan
comedy calm he's a lot of shows coming
up New York New York
Caroline's March 12th through the 14th
Tim's going to be and
Delphia Pennsylvania at helium comedy
club March 19th through the 21st he's
gonna be in Des Moines at the funny bone
in Iowa March 26 through the 28th funny
bone in Manchester Connecticut April 3rd
through the 5th
Bloomington at the house of comedy April
9th through the 11th Alberti New York
he's gonna be at the funny bone April
17th to the 19th Dallas Texas hyenas
comedy club April 23rd 24th and 25th
Phoenix Arizona he's gonna be at the
house of comedy May 7th through the 9th
Columbus Ohio he's gonna be at the funny
bone May 21st through the 24th Omaha
Nebraska May 28th to the 30th at the
funny bone he's gonna be in San
Francisco over the summer June 4th
through the 6th at the punchline he's
gonna be in Springfield Missouri
June 12th through the 13th at the Blue
Room he's going back to Canada
June 18th through the 20th in Edmonton
at the comic strip and July 7th through
July 12th he's gonna be in New York at
levity live in West Nyack I hope I'm
saying that right also remember that we
have merch we have a store on bonfire
I'll put a link in the description for
that two shirts with Tim dressed up as
Megan McCain on them we have life in the
big city shirts we have mugs we also
have a growing subreddit where you can
share clips from the show and talk to
other fans our / Tim Dylan go check that
out
follow tim on twitter at tim j dylan
follow him on instagram at Tim J Dylan
as well and that's all for now guys I
hope you enjoyed all this bonus content
and we'll see you next week